[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في عام 1937
بعد قرار مجلس الشورى وافق عليها الملك
عبد العزيز طيب الله الثراه ونشهر في في
صحيفه ام القرى
اقر الملك من بعد موافقتها على قرار مجلس
الشورى علم الملك
والعلم الوطني وعلم الملك وعلم سمول العهد
والعلم البحري والعلم التجاري وعلم الجيش
وعلم الطيران العلم في ذلك الوقت في عهد
الملك عبد العزيز والمعلومه قد لا يعرف
الكثير انه الملك عبد العزيز
العلم الخاص بالملك والعلم الخاص بسمه ولي
العهد هو ما تراه الان امامك اللي يحمل
نعم سيفاني متقاطعان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قمت
بتوثيقها وسالت عن اكبر المراكز العالميه
وكان من ضمنها مركز سيران في فرنسا
لتوثيق مثل هذه القطعه ما هي مهام هذا
المركز المركز من اكبر المراكز في العالم
في عمليه رصد وبحث وتحليل
القطع او من ضمنها القطعه القماش
بمركز معتمد حللت مجموعه من الاعلام التي
اقتنيها من ضمن هذه القطعه وهذا اشاروا
انه في حدود 1727 في هذه المرحله هذا
العلم يعني دعنا نقول بحدود 300 عام الا
قليلا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]